most men are not trashing
like the mother of their kids like that
publicly i do recognize the impact that
my relationship has had on my family and
i've never had the opportunity to just
say i'm sorry guys
kim kardashian addressing her drama with
kanye west and the consequences it's had
on her family you just gotta roll with
it
on hulu's the kardashians the reality
star reacts to the rapper dropping a new
single oh look
this is what
your friend sent me today a few minutes
ago a little while ago
i just got that same text
well
very classy
said kanye's coming out with a new rap
song what does that mean it means he's
talking mad about me and probably saying
whatever
it should be noted the specific song
they're referring to is unclear since
the series films months in advance
but based on the timeline seems like
easy could be a good guess it's a collab
featuring the game that yay dropped in
march
ain't no love
shoulder shrug you're the mother of his
kids and have done nothing
but be great to him
with kim clearly stressed her tight-knit
family quickly comes to her defense
the truth always prevails so karma is
always going to be on your side yeah and
you'll never regret being a good person
you never stoop to other people
as kim tells it even though she can't
control the situation she apologizes to
her loved ones
i think that i will never stop being me
like all i can do is control how i react
to something i can't control
what other people do how he treats me
yeah you know or how he's always treated
you guys
i do recognize the impact that my
relationship has had on my family and
i've never had the opportunity to just
say i'm sorry guys
kim ends the discussion by sharing a
personal message about how she plans to
manage the drama moving forward
and i protected that for so long but i
said i will never let that happen to you
guys again and like i
feel for once like in my life like i
feel strong i'm not gonna let anyone
treat you guys away or
myself
and at the center of kanye's recent
attacks kim's boyfriend pete davidson
like in his bizarre music video for easy
god send me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
kim's romance with the comedian is rock
solid
he's just super genuine
a source explains to et that the skim's
founder sees a strong healthy and
promising future together quote he is so
respectful of her and treats her like an
absolute queen he is completely enamored
by her beauty and talent
[Applause]
but let's not get ahead of ourselves
because when it comes to taking the next
step the source adds kim isn't quite
there yet
she still has a lot of unresolved issues
with kanye going on and now isn't the
time but solidifying their relationship
further is a definite possibility down
the road
[Music]